how can a screenwriter create a hero
that we want to follow I keep saying the
same thing but it's for me that you find
you start with the characters a really
strong emotional want and I feel like we
take any any successful film critically
acclaimed film it's always character
that has that strong emotional want
whether it's in mention with the
wrestler that my upbringing I have
nothing in common with a wrestler the
nut boys don't cry a million dollar yeah
baby baby I don't have anything in
common with a white-trash girl who wants
to box but boy did she have a want yeah
and so that's and I don't mean to say
that in a I'm trying to say the opposite
that so I'm not trying to make a
judgment or be snobby I'm saying that a
great film has a character with a strong
emotional want that no matter what our
upbringing our race we can identify and
relate to that character the protagonist
and Barry Jenkins film moonlight I don't
know what it's like to grow up as a
young black gay man in Miami but we can
all relate to feeling like an outsider
at some point in our lives wanting to be
accepted having very extraordinarily
difficult situations and there was such
beauty in the way this character was
able to persevere and overcome and then
it was also told structurally in a very
interesting manner and again there is an
example where that didn't follow what a
lot of people would say is a you know
the classic Syd field or Bob McKee
structure it was told almost like three
more I would say Alma not quite Faulkner
but there was a novelistic approach to
it I think you can break structure when
you're when you understand
to begin with and you're here you're
hitting everything else really right so
rating authentic characters compelling
dialogue compelling situations and it is
well structured so but I do feel it's
like tapping into that thing that we as
humans want and can identify with and
what are universal flaws that that a
character may have
you